si no hay un gobierno pues obviamente el
acuerdo se va a caer porque no existe la
aprobación del ente legislativo y en ese
sentido yo creo que la falta de cuadros
que tiene el partido de gobierno es
decir la falta de políticos
experimentados pues va a traer a pasar
factura al nuevo gobierno en el sentido
de que no haber un enlace una
comunicación entre la presidencia y
obviamente el congreso para tratar de
conciliar la agenda y en ese sentido de
alguna forma el acuerdo depende depende
de que efectivamente en un congreso que
obviamente está con mayoría opositora
pues obviamente no va a tener digamos
una confiabilidad muy mayor digámoslo
así en torno a que los que busca el
presidente chávez con el nuevo acuerdo
pues es lo que al final de cuentas
piense o trate de aprobar el digamos el
parlamento entonces yo creo que más allá
de la cuestión del acuerdo es
básicamente formar gobierno formar
gobernabilidad para que digamos no
solamente el acuerdo sino otros temas de
la agenda la costarricense pues fluyan
de manera armónica entre ambos poderes